[Music]
well
i like to write i don't type
for drama you're gonna have two you got
people button heads you gotta believe
in what you do what you have
and you have to work on your craft
whatever it is
you gotta work on it you gotta make a
way when there doesn't seem to be a way
you gotta make a way
write about yourself write about what
you know
find your voice and work on your voice
i still feel i'm very blessed because
i'm doing what i love
and that's making films
write about yourself write about what
you know
there's some other stuff you know
nothing about you're not going to do
spending time or money do the research
to learn
whatever you're trying to do so just try
to pull
something from within
find your voice and work on your voice
because everybody does not have the gift
of knowing exactly
what they want to say and be honest
a lot of times people have not
discovered who they are
every movie is hard
for the filmmakers who are here
in audience there's nothing easy about
filmmaking it's hard to make a terrible
film
so but
when you're surrounded by people in
front of the camera and
everybody's united and simpatico and
constant what you're trying to do
that's where the fun you know comes from
i would give the same advice
to inspiring filmmaker and writer
write both of those
disciplines you need to write
and it's something i tell my film
students i've been teaching i've been a
professor at nyu the last 15 years
in the graduate film school where i went
and if you did a survey the last 25
years
and looked at the first films
of directors i would say a large
percentage of those films
those directors wrote that script
so i think that's a big clue
when i'm talking about film that if you
want to be a director
you could write also you're
got a much better chance of getting your
first film made
for drama you gotta have two you got
people button heads
and it elevates the drama when they're
both
what they're saying is right so let's
let's let's break this down
buggins out like [ __ ] you sound
i'm tired of [ __ ] italians i
ain't done a story about
on the wall there no
no there's not a busload of time
americans coming from bensonhurst howard
beach
the beds died due to dying not 989
your livelihood
consists of black and puerto rican
people
spending money and your pizzeria
it was danielle's danielle pronounced
the pizzeria
so therefore don't you think you just
it would be respectful it has some black
people on the wall
that's a valid point let's go to bugging
out
that's who i just do sour which one i
just do
sal boog it out yeah but i just saw
now sal's like yo [ __ ]
if you want a pizzeria
build your [ __ ]
this is my business and i could do
what i want like hollywood
yes so there's the drama
two people who are
who believe in their beliefs
and they're going head-to-head
how are you growing as a filmmaker well
i'm going all the time i think one of
the reasons why uh
i continue and always hope to make films
is because there's so much to learn
with this with this thing called cinema
i mean curacao one of the greatest
filmmakers ever he's 86 87 years old he
still says there's things he doesn't
know
if he could say that then you then i you
know i there's no i could
even attempt to say that i know
everything about filmmaking
and i myself see growth in my film
she's going to have it school days do
the right thing mo better jungle fever
malcolm x
to me is you know we're going up
you mentioned not just me but everybody
i work with robert reed
cast my films ernest dickerson who
shoots him ruthie carter the costume
designer
we all win thomas productions design all
of us work together since she's got to
have it
i believe you said in an interview with
nyu
that you can't stand a lazy student
right what do you see in most
independent filmmakers however old they
are
that makes them lazy and that hinders
their career well i don't want to make a
blanket statements about
independent filmmakers but i've had
students who are lazy
and laziness is something i really can't
tolerate
so because of laziness i think that that
speaks of a sense of entitlement
and
that's just not a good look in this
industry where you think that
you are entitled to something that you
did you deserve something because
you're wherever you think you are it
doesn't work like that
to make it you got to bust your black
ass
you got to be relentless
you got to persevere you gotta be
focused
and you gotta believe in what
you do what you have and you have to
work on your craft whatever it is you
gotta work on it
i tell my students at nyu graduate film
school
that there's no such thing as overnight
success
it doesn't exist you gotta
work you gotta work you gotta work
your ass as that's and and another thing
i like to say is that
it's in my experience of people who are
able
to hurdle obstacles or the people
that are doing it because this is what
they want to do
this is what i love this is my calling
versus the people who are doing it
because i want to make money be famous
but when you use obstacles that
goal is not going to get you over
it's not going to equal
the fire you're going to have in you if
you do it because
you had you're saying so i have to do
this
i have to express myself i have to tell
my story
i have to write this play i have to
write this movie i have to write this
song
that's that's where
you can make it happen but you got to
work
i've been doing this 30 years you know
you got to work
and i'm still learning you know so you
got to you gotta work you
can never ever ever
get to that mentality like you know it
all
like you can't work on your craft that's
that ain't gonna make it you got you
gotta you gotta
make films people making feature films
on their their phones
you gotta make it and get it seen
film this is right here my man right
here
but you cannot underestimate
who sees your film a whole bunch of
people
they put their stuff up i mean these
these
agencies and studios they have people
who the only job is to look at stuff on
internet
you know so that's
definitely a way to
to get seen but you all at the same time
you got to develop your own voice if
you're doing something where you're just
imitating something that's you know hot
or
trendy you know that's they're looking
for original voices so
i think at this at this stage try to
develop your voice
so you're a filmmaker if you're trying
to be a filmmaker
you have to understand this is a craft
and and you have you don't have to go to
film school
i'm gonna say it again you don't have to
go to film school to be a filmmaker
the only reason why i went to nyu
because at that time
we did not have this digital technology
then
the greatest obstacle to making films
was
getting access to equipment
and so my generation went to film school
we did not go to film school to get a
degree
a degree in mfa from nyu or usc doesn't
mean anything when you come out of film
school
if you're directing you need to come out
with the film if you're a writer you
need to come out
a screenplay if you're deep you need to
come up with the real
so we didn't care about the degree
we wanted to come out with the film
and again my generation it was for the
digital technology so
you had to get access to the film by
going to film school yet you got
access to the equipment your crew was
your class
mates nyu and all film schools have
agreement with sag so you got the word
with actors free
you have to pay for actors and you also
had access
to the facilities to edit so that's why
i went to film school
well i like to write
i don't type pen to paper
[Music]
but the way my brain works this doesn't
work it it
it blocks the flow his mother says you
always have to be ten
times better so he keeps writing and
does not stop
he writes about the heat about the game
about the block and home he writes with
his heart
his music his way of seeing things and
always by
hand his left hand and it keeps writing
and writing and writing right into all
cuts to black
you